With Black Lightning, DC launched its first
television show starring a black superhero.
It's a milestone that's been a long time coming,
but it's not the first time Jefferson Pierce
has managed to break a long-standing barrier:
since first appearing over 40 years ago, he’s
served as a member of the Justice League,
the Outsiders, a solo superhero, and even
provided the DC Universe with a legacy of
heroic characters.
From his origins on the page all the way to
his current status on the screen, here's the
fascinating truth behind Black Lightning.
DC's First Black Superhero
The first three decades of the superhero genre
were overwhelmingly white, but in the late
'60s, that began to change.
At Marvel, Stan Lee and Jack Kirby introduced
the Black Panther, and in 1973, Hero For Hire
#1 made Luke Cage the first black superhero
to headline his own book.
At DC, however, things moved a little more
slowly.
It wasn’t until 1977 that Tony Isabella,
a writer who had previously worked on Luke
Cage's adventures, was hired to create their
first headlining black superhero.
With Isabella and artist Trevor von Eeden,
that year saw the debut of Black Lightning.
Jefferson Pierce was a Gold Medal-winning
Olympic decathlete who returned to his old
neighborhood in Metropolis to work as a teacher.
When one of his students was killed in an
altercation with the a criminal organization
called the 100, Pierce decided to hit the
streets with a high-tech costume to take them
on himself.
The Black Bomber, the hero that almost was
While Black Lightning was the idea that made
it to the page, he wasn’t DC’s first thought
when it came to creating a black superhero
— and as Isabella revealed on his blog,
the original plan might’ve been the worst
idea in comics history.
When Isabella was hired, the editors pitched
him a character called the Black Bomber, with
the hook being that he was actually a white
racist who turned into a super-powered black
man when he was stressed out, with neither
personality being aware of the other.
In other words, DC's first black superhero
was not actually going to be black, and would
feature plenty of stereotypes including a
basketball uniform costume.
Fortunately for everyone concerned, Isabella
talked them out of it.
Thirty years later, though, writer Dwayne
McDuffie, well known for making satirical
jabs at the superhero genre, worked him into
a story about an alternate reality where everything
had gone so wrong that the Brown Bomber could
be on the Justice League.
The Outsiders
The original run of Black Lightning was canceled
after only 11 issues, but if it's any consolation,
it wasn't alone.
Instead, it was a casualty of what fans have
dubbed the DC Implosion.
All told, DC gave the axe to 20 titles.
It was a move that came so suddenly that most
of those series even had completely finished
stories, including Black Lightning #12, that
stayed in DC's archives until they were published
in a book called Cancelled Comic Cavalcade
to secure the copyrights.
Five years later, Black Lightning got a second
chance at stardom.
When Batman quit the Justice League over that
team's reluctance to cause an international
incident, he put together a new team called
the Outsiders.
The roster included a handful of new characters
like Katana, who would go on to appear in
the Suicide Squad movie, but it also revived
a few existing heroes, including Black Lightning.
Over the course of the Outsiders' five-year
run, everyone on the team got a spotlight
story highlighting their mysterious and/or
tortured past, and Black Lightning was no
exception.
In his case, he'd given up his costumed identity
and powers due to guilt over the accidental
death of a bystander named Trina Shelton,
whose family would eventually return to get
revenge.
I'm the one who taught him to fly!
Black Lightning headlining his own show is
a new development, but Cress Williams isn't
actually the first actor to ever play the
character in live action.
That honor, believe it or not, goes to stand-up
comedian Sinbad, who took a brief turn as
Black Lightning on a 1992 episode of Saturday
Night Live.
In a sketch set at Superman's funeral, tying
into the then-current Death of Superman storyline,
cast members like Chris Farley, Dana Carvey,
and Chris Rock appeared as Superman's fellow
heroes.
However, Black Lightning wasn't invited, leading
to an altercation with Jimmy Olsen.
And… by the way - SNL effects department
- that's not what lightning looks like.
It's not the most flattering portrayal for
sure —and the part where Batman doesn't
recognize his old teammate is a real heartbreaker
— but it is an interesting bit of pop cultural
prominence for a character who was still pretty
obscure for mainstream audiences.
Thunder, Lightning, and Grace
With Black Lightning's ties to the original
roster of the Outsiders, it's not surprising
that he'd have a connection to the team when
a new version was put together in 2003.
In Outsiders #1, Judd Winick and Tom Raney
introduced Anissa Pierce, AKA Thunder, the
oldest of Black Lightning's two daughters.
Like her father, Anissa added some much-needed
diversity to the DC Universe when it was revealed
that she was in a romantic relationship with
another member of the outsiders, Grace Choi.
Her powers, however, are completely different.
She can control her density, making her nearly
invulnerable.
In 2008, Anissa’s younger sister Jennifer
— originally introduced as part of another
alternate reality in the pages of Kingdom
Come — joined her in the mainstream continuity.
With powers that were similar to her father’s,
she took the name “Lightning.”
Joining the Justice League
In 1979, Black Lightning was offered membership
in the JLA, but turned it down, becoming only
the second character ever to do so.
30 years later, he finally accepted.
In 2006, Batman, Superman, and Wonder Woman
spent a story arc literally sitting around
a table with a bunch of trading card-style
photographs of their fellow heroes, debating
who they should let into a reformed League.
Around that same time, a swamp zombie rebuilt
a killer robot so he could turn Red Tornado
human and then tear off his arm and eat it.
Yeah, that really happened… but anyway that
was the McGuffin to get Black Lightning, and
the rest, to join up.
The Justice League decided to just keep everyone
who showed up to fight the latest crisis,
and he stuck around for the next few years.
After DC rebooted their universe in 2011,
and then "rebirthed" it in 2016, he was out
of the League and back to being a solo hero.
The CW's Black Lightning
With the new Black Lightning TV show, the
CW is pulling from the entire history of the
character in some pretty interesting ways.
Cress Williams stars as Jefferson Pierce,
who still works in education in his TV incarnation.
He's the principal of a high school in the
city of Freeland who has dedicated his tenure
to helping kids and eliminating violence.
Like his earliest comics incarnation, the
CW's Black Lightning is taking on the 100
and Tobias Whale, and getting his costume
and equipment from Peter Gambi.
Like the version that showed up in Batman
and the Outsiders, he's been retired from
superheroics, driven to give up on being a
vigilante by his aversion to violence.
Anissa and Jennifer have already appeared
on the show, both with the powers they have
the comics, and Grace Choi is there as Anissa’s
love interest.
The only thing that could really complete
the saga is if they managed to get an appearance
by Sinbad.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!